foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored King
Charles sensationally slaps down Harry
and Megan with an eviction notice and
Paul's salt in the wound by offering the
keys to their Cottage to prince Andrew
will he now banish the sausages from his
coronation
and a stunning tranche of a hundred
thousand lead messages laid Bare The
Deadly Fiasco that saw covid tear
through England's nursing homes Isabel
Oaks shop she broke the story and she's
giving me her first interview live
tonight we'll debate whether Matt
Hancock could now face criminal justice
charges plus a convicted male pedophile
switches genders after he accused a
murder but the prosecutor is suspended
for refusing to call them she
hey I'll talk to him I think he's a him
live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening Rolanda welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored no matter what
your views on lockdowns the covert
pandemic was redefining Health crisis of
our time the virus has killed almost 7
million people worldwide and 219 000 in
Britain alone debate will rage for years
about how many of those deaths could
have been prevented by intelligent
governance and better decisions a public
inquiry in the UK is creaking into
action it took more than a year just to
agree its terms of reference it's
already cost up to 85 million pounds and
hasn't even started for more hearings
Sweden have already had theirs it's done
and dusted
What's Happening Here is scandalous it's
maximum attempt to wrap deadly
incompetence and red tape suffocate
public anger by attrition and delay we
don't need hindsight or inquiry to know
that expensive and fatally negligent
mistakes were made in Britain we don't
need hindsight and inquiry to know that
Matt Hancock our health secretary at the
time was utterly unsuited to the gravity
of the job he faced nothing more than
that more Dev was made more devastating
and clear than the tragedy in our Care
Homes a reminder this is what Matt
Hancock said about care homes in May
right from the start it's been clear
that this horrible virus affects older
people most
so right from the start we've tried to
throw a protective ring around our Care
Homes well three days later he said this
well we absolutely did throw a
protective ring around social care and
not least with the 3.2 billion pounds
worth of funding we put in right at the
start
and the next day he told MPS this
and I'm glad we've been able to protect
the majority of homes and we'll keep
working to strengthen the protective
ring that we've cast around all our Care
Homes protective ring protective ring
protective ring around cures but there
was no protective ring at all in fact
Hancock sent thousands of elderly
patients from hospitals back to their
nursing homes without even testing most
of them covers spread like wildfire
inside those homes was a deadly Fiasco
of a policy from a travesty of a health
secretary with tragic consequences for
thousands of families this is what I
said to him at the time
I'm really struck by the fact that you
feel incensed that we're not thanking
you enough for your handling of this
pandemicism
it didn't save lives did you we've got
130 000 deaths the worst death toll in
Europe we have one of the worst death
rates in the world so I just don't know
why I should be thanking you
I still don't to be honest not sure the
words thank you Mr Hancock are
appropriate well now a stunning tranche
of private messages given by Hancock to
journalist Isabel oakshot to write his
Memoir were published in the Daily
Telegraph today and they've laid bare
the shocking extent of Hancock's failure
right from the very beginning on
November the 14th 2020 Mr Hancock told
his advisors Chris Woody has done an
Evidence review and now recommended
testing going to All Care Homes and
segregation whilst awaiting result that
would make obvious sense this is
obviously a good positive Step at
Hancock and we must put it into the dock
but later that same day Hancock said
this tell me I'm wrong but I would
rather leave it out and just commit to
test and isolate all going into care
from hospital I don't think the
community commitment adds anything and
it muddies the waters wow muddies the
waters
to not bother about people coming from
communities into Care Homes
not testing them or even trying to
extraordinary Turner phrase the chief
medical officer's advice finally became
government policy on August 14th five
months later between the date of his
advice and the date of Hancock finally
taking my advice 17
678 people died of covert in care homes
in England
well later on Hancock reluctantly agreed
to include care homes in his testing
program but only if it didn't quote get
in the way closed quotes of his elf's
own self-aggrandizing Target of a
hundred thousand tests a day the texts
showed that he used loopholes to inflate
the figures and beg for favors to save
his own reputation I want to hit my
target he's told George Osborne then the
evening standards editor when he was
asking for a front page I gathered was
Osborne's withering reply there are many
more Revelations to today's leagues we
learned that Jacob Reese mogg had a test
Courier to his home for one of his
children at a time when there was a
national shortage and that Boris Johnson
was going crackers at Britain's testing
incompetence there's a lot more to come
but we already have a very Grim picture
of a negligent Health secretary whose
vanity and arrogance by far exceeded his
abilities it now looks beyond doubt that
that vanity in arrogance may have also
cost many many lies well joining me now
for her first interview about all this
is the journalist at the center of the
covid WhatsApp League sensation talk
TV's International editor Isabella and
talk to you these political editor Kate
McCann Daily Mirror associate editor
Kevin McGuire
Isabel wow but it dropped last night 10
45. uh it was quite something to read
all this particularly for people like me
who obviously were on air throughout
this pandemic and involved in pretty
heated discussions with people like Matt
Hancock in which frankly they lied
through their back teeth about what was
really going on to see in their WhatsApp
messages the cold hard reality were
shocking
you've had this for a while what made
you I mean let's be brutally honest
about what you did you did a book with
Matt Hancock as part of the preparation
of the book he gives you a hundred
thousand what's that message is between
him and and members of the cabinet the
Prime Minister you don't put them in the
book he says you signed an NDA to stop
you using these and you've now
presumably broken the NDA given these to
the Daily Telegraph of publication he
says you've stolen them blah blah blah
what is your reaction to all this well
first of all please I'm very aware of
how robustly uh you fought for public
accountability from our politicians
during this period I can tell you that
your name does crop up in some of these
messages I would hope so I'm sure we'll
come to that uh later in the week look
you mentioned in your introduction uh
the absolute fast that is the public
inquiry Arrangement so far this public
inquiry if you look at the terms of
reference I could spend a year on each
one of about the 30 things that they
have been asked to consider the judge
who is somebody of the highest integrity
and has a great reputation no doubt will
want to do justice to every one of those
things she's not been given a deadline
so the reality is that this inquiry
which I think is absolutely critical
will likely not come up with any
conclusions left to the government's own
devices perhaps for at least a decade or
more now we could have another pandemic
next month next year who knows when the
next one is coming we cannot afford to
wait for a decade or more for answers as
to what was really going on so this
resource that I had is an extraordinary
way to quickly get to the truth of what
really happened why crucial decisions
were made that affected millions of
lives that millions of people are still
paying the price for today without us
having to be fobbed off with an inquiry
which I'm afraid is most likely going to
end up for the best intentions of
everyone involved being a whitewash so
Lord Bethel who is a health minister at
the time has told Tom Newton done for
his show tonight on talk TV Isabel Oak
shot has no idea what went on those in
those rooms she hasn't seen the paper
she's seen a few whatsapps from around
the edges she's fooling herself if she
thinks that's really given her an
Insight what she's taken is a bunch of
fluff that was in Trans in transient
transient transient I think that means
what's that messages and pretend that
it's substantive insight into the
evidence-based decision that's been made
is simply not true it's a confection and
quite frankly the telegraph should be
ashamed of themselves what an
embarrassing and pathetic and lame
defense uh from Lord Bethel there I
imagine the battle's rather nervous
because he is one of the most Indiscreet
people in these WhatsApp messages uh
highly revelatory for him to dismiss
them as a few WhatsApp messages which I
heard him say this morning the entire
volume of this is almost three times the
size of the Bible it's not a few
messages and the reality is that the
WhatsApp groups were used routinely
minute by minute to communicate critical
Decisions by the way there is an
argument they should be public record
right I mean in America every
communication like this with the prime
minister with the president would be
public record so you can't do privately
yeah if he's saying that this is a
partial account I am all he is for the
rest of it and I'm sure that the
neighborhood is very grateful if all the
whatsapps from every Minister involved
were released now your position is that
this is in the public interest 100 let
me just ask you to the specifics which
Hancock has said by word of response did
you sign an NDA which pledged not to use
these messages yes so you've
deliberately broken that I have in the
public interest and that could be there
could be legal consequences the public
interest is overwhelming whenever you
break a big story which is in the
National interest and I've done a few of
them it can be a rocky road it can be a
bumpy ride look I know that I'm going to
get a few knocks over this I'm prepared
to do this because I think that the
national interest is so utterly
compelling another difficult question
the cynic would say well hang on you've
just done this Memoir with this guy
which has enriched him right and in the
Memoir you say that he's very persuasive
and you know you thought he had good
arguments and so on not a sign now of
what you're now saying about it and a
cynic would say well come on Isabel you
did this Memoir with him why won't you
you're more honest if you really felt
this way why not just pull away from
writing the book with him and expose all
this at the time rather than allow this
sham of a book to come out well he
glossed over everything it made him have
to be some kind of hero I think that's
quite unfair I don't know whether you've
read every every word I couldn't get
through all of it well even though it
was so beautifully written by me
actually judging by the sales thing is
my point being that I'm really happy to
address that yeah because I think it is
an important one
um and the reality is I would of course
not have put my name to anything that I
thought was an untruth the other reality
is that there are nearly three million
words in these WhatsApp messages
I was working on this book against the
clock it was a phenomenal effort it was
twice the length of any normal political
book it was simply impossible to go
through every line of those WhatsApp
messages and of course equally the book
is Matt Hancock's diary it's his truth
when did he know that you'd done this
late last night wow when everybody else
did yeah did you have any convulsion at
all about frying a contact like someone
you've written a book with
uh I'm not gonna sit here and uh
disparage Matt Hancock personally
because this is not about well yeah
you've just told you for me for me this
is not about it this is not about you
have as a journalist you've written a
book with this guy and within months of
the book coming out
you've talked right I mean you've fried
the contact you've ripped up the NDA you
published all the messages I'm not
taking a judgment I'm just saying you
have done that there are many things I
could sit here and say about Matt
Hancock which I'm not going to do now
but it seems a good time I'm not going
to do because this for me is not a
personal thing is it true that he is it
true that he went back on his word with
you in relation to your business
arrangement with the book
uh
uh again I don't want to get into that
he's certainly undertook to do an
interview with talk TV which was very
important to me as International editor
of talk TV he reneged on that it's of
course not the reason why I did this I
cannot emphasize enough this is not
personal against about Hancock I can see
many good qualities in him we had a good
working relationship
by and large
um various aspects towards the end we're
not quite have you heard from him since
since the publication of this yes I have
what did he say I received a somewhat
menacing message at 1 20 in the morning
I'm not going to repeat what was in the
message
um but yeah I'm saying menacing what was
well uh I think you can easily surmise
whether Matt Hancock is my friend at
this point oh sure he's not but I mean
what does menacing mean we threatened
you
I I I think that he um is extremely
troubled in terms of how to respond to
this and I I don't blame him but this is
not about him as far as I'm concerned it
is much bigger than that it is about
understanding the truth of what really I
understand that
um specifically he says it's been edited
that there were other WhatsApp exchanges
I think is that he's withdrawn that no
it isn't it's emphatically inaccurate we
specifically refer to that meeting I
think it's on page four of the coverage
he simply hasn't read the inside story
is there any is there any doubt from
everything you've read is there any
doubt at all that the veracity of that
main charge in the telegraph Revelations
today about the care homes and about him
overriding the advice from the chief
medical officer that that is entirely
true there's no doubt in my mind that
what the telegraph of printed today is
an accurate reflection the telegraph has
been exceptionally careful not to
selectively quote from these messages
look look they're not Daft they know
that that would be a very easy stick to
beat them with so they have been very
careful also the telegraph doesn't over
claim for any of this of course we know
there are other people whose
conversations we don't have access to
that is entirely obvious okay
YouTube been sitting here listening to
all this I mean look from a journalistic
point of view I picked I picked up the
telegraph the morning there's a
sensation I mean this was extraordinary
reading to go through all this
um I think I'll put the tough questions
to isabone she's been robust in
responding from a political point of
view first Katie what has been the
reaction to this and what are the likely
consequences if anything so there's been
a couple of different reactions clearly
Matt Hancock and his team very very
frustrated and unhappy Helen Whiteley
you know a minister who was sort of
talking about this today suggests that
there was a meeting in between all of
this advice being you know given to Matt
Hancock where the political reality came
up against the scientific advice and I
think this has been a problem all the
way through this story in fact all the
way through covid there is a difference
between scientific advice and the
reality of what can happen on the ground
and Matt Hancock's point would be yes
Chris what's the advice we do this the
capacity wasn't there to do it therefore
you know we were forced to scale it back
and we did it as soon as we could what I
actually think is that some of the
messages in here do reveal something
quite problematic for the government
which is about the way that Care Homes
were not prioritized Helen waiteley's
messages inside the telegraph showing
her saying we have a problem with PPE we
don't have enough and I can't get anyone
to tell me when I will have enough and
she's asking you know quite nicely of
the of the house I mean I interviewed
Helen Whiteley several times in that
period I thought she was completely out
of her depth which I thought summarized
my view of that government a young
rookie government just come in a lot of
them completely out of their debt didn't
know what but then did you change your
mind when you read this because I
actually well I had a slightly more
sympathy with her that she had clearly
been asking for this stuff but clearly
wasn't getting it back I mean Kevin from
well first of all from a journalistic
point of view
what do you think about what Isabel did
here oh Isabelle's accused of stabbing
Hancock in the in the back and she'll
have to deal with the journalistic
ethics but is there a public interest
defense for that but yes clearly and are
we in a better position tonight than we
were last night on Covert yes we are
that's what I think because she's made
though this has made them public she'll
have to take the uh The Knocks as well
as the uh the praise for that but we get
an incredible insight into what was
really happening what do you feel you
know now you didn't yesterday that he
didn't that Hancock didn't follow always
a scientific advice yes he was Guided by
it at times and it can accept right
covert appears almost from a clear blue
sky it's a huge catastrophe a real
challenge you're making decisions in
real time with resource limitations you
haven't got the organization right so
mistakes will be made but because of
some of those mistakes people died they
died we can't get away from it and by
the way in Care Homes thousands and
thousands of people died I know people
who lost their relatives who lost their
mother their father absolutely in the
Care Homes and payers I can see this is
very inconvenient for Matt Hancock
because he he wants to reinvent himself
as a lad locking around on reality TV no
doubt doing a lot of gigs you know at
dinners and so on and getting paid well
people aren't going to be laughing now
they're not and they realize one person
who definitely won't be laughing is the
owner of Crabtree Care Homes David
Crabtree David we've spoken many times
throughout the pandemic and and again uh
in the last few months what is your
reaction to these Revelations about Matt
Hancock in particular in the telegraph
if you go back thank you Peter if you go
back and and thank you for for being a
stowa for the care sector thank you if
you go back to your opening section
where he was speaking he said from the
very start from the very start well from
the very start he lied and he lied and
he lied and he continues to lie it's not
that we got things wrong pandemic was
new to everyone it's that he lied after
the event and continues to lie and what
happens with its lies and all of this
publicity is he reinvoked all the anger
and upset the loss of life the relatives
he risked it wasn't just the elderly he
was risking the mother of two that was
coming to work at seven o'clock with no
PPE everything this man does
is characterized by an inadequate
sociopath everything he does if you look
it up there's his characteristic I wish
to goodness he would just disappear
because he's managed to destroy his own
career is is is his relationships
I I cannot tell you how incensed the
care sector is yeah every time this
man's name is mentioned yeah no I I know
I've heard it from from them myself okay
lots of people's names are in these
WhatsApp messages you know Boris
Johnson's there liberally Rishi sunak
we're told is in a lot of them too
Isabel you can confirm that yeah
absolutely so the current prime minister
is I mean there must be all be on ten
terms right waiting for the next
installment tonight uh with all these
Revelations this afternoon that
apparently we only follow for example
what Scotland did in relation to kids
wearing masks and stuff because they
didn't want to you know make a problem
with Nicholas sturgeon in Scotland which
seems to be an extraordinary Revelation
never mind anything else yeah I think it
is and actually it's a point you raise a
point that's going to be a much bigger
issue for Westminster know and it's
going to have huge repercussions today
at the lobby briefing for journalists
active prime minister's questions the
questions were repeatedly about how do
ministers use their phones are they
using deletion on WhatsApp as a regular
thing you said that they should be held
to account that those messages should be
public record they are peers they are
public record except from who is
checking that that happens right now and
the Prime Minister spokesman was asked
that today and he said well there is a
policy on this you are actually as a
minister if you are discussing policy
you're allowed to do that on WhatsApp
but you have to then ensure that it is
recorded So that any official decision
which is not allowed to be made on whats
that book can be discussed is then there
as public record at the moment I'm not
sure that the government can guarantee
comfortably that that I'm sure I'm sure
they can't Isabel are there Revelations
to come which could cause the current
prime minister problems
um I think that the current prime
minister in his capacity as Chancellor
was doing what chancellors should do and
protecting the public purse um nothing
damaging about it I don't want to
comment on what's to come up I'm sure
you'll understand that um but I think
that this issue that you raise about the
use of whatsapps goes to the heart of
why it's so important for people to see
the way decisions were made the
casualness the informality of you know a
few meets an incredibly powerful
positions with a thumbs up or thumbs
down deciding the fate of millions of
people we look you can under certain
circumstances get them under a freedom
of information request but it's worth
saying Lord Bethel the health minister
at the time who's had to go at Isabel
there's a sticker for herself he lost a
lot of his WhatsApp messages on Covert
contracts when he was transferring
phones it wasn't quite it wasn't quite
uh wagatha Christie the phone going over
the side of a boat but nevertheless
those messages have been lost forever so
when are years ago what other people I
think hang on Bethel yeah some of some
of your messages have gone already no
it's it's government by WhatsApp now
Tony Blair used to be by sofa it's
shifted is everyone okay in Westminster
basically waiting for the telegraph to
drop tonight
yeah I think people are and they will be
probably for some time but I do think
that this goes beyond as we're saying
here it's beyond Matt Hancock it's about
how policy is made in this country and I
think it's about the fact that a lot of
these decisions when you read them you
may not look at them and think wow so
there's The Smoking Gun but actually
it's more subtle than that it's about
the way that these decisions were made I
just remember the certainty that Hancock
was saying we put a protective ring
around here he did not put a protective
ring around Care Homes he let a lot of
people back from hospital without
testing them up like hospitals were Rife
with covid he let anyone from the
community Come and Go including the
carers including family members to start
with the whole thing was totally what
was the point your guest was making
which was seemingly and I don't know
whether he believes this I don't want to
speak for him but if actually the
government had been honest and said we
we can't do this yet we would love to
we're going to try as soon as we can
well let's ask David Crabtree that
finally that very question David had you
known these issues of the government and
we're now reading about you would have
presumably acted differently
you don't need to be a scientist to know
that you don't admit potentially
infected people into a care home when
Professor Valance in January said these
would be breeding grounds and we watched
it across Italy and France before it
arrived at our doorstep we already knew
to shut the door to try and minimize we
accepted that this was you know there
was a pandemic On and nobody had any PPE
or whatever we did the best we could and
we accept that errors were made what is
the anger is invoked because they now
lie to cover it up we would have coped
as we would cope with diarrhea and
sickness with flu epidemic with all the
others that we normally associate
through winter we're not stupid we've
been doing it a long time we don't need
a scientist what we do need is truth
factual we don't have enough this is
what we're going to do we're going to
try and help you don't lie to us and say
that you put a ring of protection around
us David how many how many people did
you lose in the pandemic from
we lost 8 18 over two homes that's just
us but across Bradford we lost thousands
absolutely shocking it was shocking
David thank you for your your passion
you're always the relatives couldn't the
relatives couldn't go in nobody could
see anybody so people were losing their
loved ones without seeing them it was
awful I know a good friend of mine had
to say goodbye to her beloved mother on
FaceTime
in a car when it ripped through the care
I mean imagine that I still haunts me to
this day thinking about it David thank
you very much indeed for joining me
thank you if if we could just get an
apology off Mr Hancock that would do us
you know what I think you've got more
chance honestly of him handing back the
money from eating kangaroo testicles in
the jungle but a good idea David uh
Isabel I think it's a fantastic scoop uh
there's an argument to be had about
whether it's all the public I think it's
overwhelming in the public interest
um and so I'm looking forward to reading
more Revelations thank you so uh I think
congratulations are in order to exposing
this frankly okay thank you very much
for joining me that's gonna be
interesting to see a reaction Tomorrow
there's more Revelations to come back
tonight Hey Kevin you're staying with me
thank you you've got the Short Straw you
two in morning by the way in the
Blackford Hancock's career or yeah
accidental
good to see you well next tonight
they're out King Charles is evicted
Harry and Megan from their UK home from
Cottage a couple has confirmed that
tonight will they now also be banned
from the coronation well
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking good I'm loving it look let's be
honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture
there's no subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
big breaking news Arsenal are wondering
up in the game against Everton uh and if
you're watching I'll catch up that may
have been overtaken by events hopefully
we're now winning three nil uh well King
Charles is sensationally evicted Harry
and Megan from Frogmore Cottage in
Windsor and reportedly offered it now to
prince Andrew who has to vacate his own
larger home well the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex were given the college as a
wedding gift by the queen in 2018 and
will now be left without a home in the
UK after Buckingham Palace served
eviction papers tonight A spokesman for
the couple confirmed the sun's bombshell
scoop by saying they have been requested
to vacate the property well Kevin McGraw
still remember I've been joined Now by
talk to the contributor has to Cracker
and as Jordan author uh Tessa well so
Kevin this is one of those Scooby great
Scoops
um this morning
um and complete be true it turned out
they have indeed been kicked out they've
been evicted yeah there's a new sheriff
in town and he's going to be the Iron
King because he was the act of a king
not a father in other words has he
basically put his new status as the
Monarch and the interests of the
monarchy and his role as king above
actually what maybe his instinct is as a
dad well it could be as a dad he
believes in tough love he's also said to
be very emotionally cold and probably
you know not best suited to try and
bringing them back in in a warm way but
it is pretty Sensational as you say
because I thought he would try and find
Common Ground try and build Bridges get
some peace but this is right if you're
going to go to war with me I'm going to
fight back right and it does beg the
question Esther uh coronation coming up
in early may only a few weeks away now
invitations apparently going out next
week 2 000 of them I mean I would put
good money now that there will be no
invitation heading his way to Montecito
in California I think so too look I was
very skeptical when I saw this because I
thought the palace just asked them to
take the rest of their belongings and
ship it back to Monte detail but the
fact that they've actually been given a
formal eviction notice yes it's very
clear you're not coming back there are
no warm sort of olive olive branches
being extended to you if that's a thing
uh and it's it's really quite scathing
actually can you imagine just being
evicted by your own father it is but I'm
not I've just written the column for the
sun about this and I you know you and I
we've argued about this but putting
aside our different opinions about them
as people there does come a Tipping
Point in any Feud of this nature where
if one side just continues to publicly
attack the other on the global stage
that Megan and Harry have not just with
Oprah Winfrey but then a six-part
Netflix documentary series then a 400
page book trashing everyone including
Kate and Camilla and so on there is a
Tipping Point for anybody however much
Charles may want to be a good dad
William I'm told was utterly
incandescent after that book and I think
this is the logic apparently this
decision was taken the next day after
the book came out is anyone surprised
really I'm I never think it's a good
idea to make a decision like that in
haste you then repent at leisure I think
given the coronation is as you've
mentioned but weeks away and that we
want our monarchy to look broad
shouldered to look Global to look like
it's an institution that understands
what Redemption means I think the
timing's unfortunate I think the Optics
around asking Uncle Andrew the disgraced
Jew to move in also is deeply
unfortunate although I would question
yeah that that whether this is on
numerous levels the right decision at
the right time I certainly think Kevin
the Andrew bit to me was Ill thought
through because that gives all the
people who support Megan and Harry and
don't want to believe a bad word about
them I said really you're going to put
the guy that paid this woman who says he
never met millions of dollars to avoid
having his day in court you're going to
give him their Cottage because somehow
he's better all I would say to counter
that I was in America last week and a
new poll came out while I was there
saying that they are now less popular in
America than Andrew yeah I mean that is
how far
their standing has fallen it could be
because in America they've forgotten to
some extent Andrew although he is the
real scandal in the royal family I think
Harry and Megan haven't behaved by uh we
haven't behaved well others I don't
think have behaved well on the other
side but to give him that five bedroom
house is adding insult to injury for
them I do think it's a bad move I mean
if he needs a house let him get on a
council waiting list like everybody else
why should he be gifted a multi-million
pound two oranges and Meghan markle's
yoga room
what another thing is he doesn't this
old man doesn't need a five-bedroom
house I think he needs a one-bedroom
flat and stevenage well apparently
Andrew doesn't even want Frogmore
College he wants to stay where he is
which is a much larger property he would
be seeing it as a demotion because
Andrew is pretty deluded about most
things let me ask you on the coronation
specifically it is coming up I mean
should he be invited never mind Willie
should Harry and Megan actually get an
invitation absolutely not that's what I
think
if one of my three sons all in their 20s
now and I'm very I have a great
relationship with all of them if one of
my three sons spent years publicly
trashing our family all the members in
it right and the Very institution of our
family they would not get as I put in my
column the remaining ash from my
Christmas Day cigar let alone a grace
and favor hope you're talking to in your
column you're talking to a little bit
dare I say of middle England we want our
monarchy to be bigger and better than
lap is who's weird Great Britain no we
want no we want Renegade once our world
cake and eat it Royals yeah who've been
treachery to stay in California and
actually sink or swim by being Megan and
Harris not the Duke and Duchess it looks
like you're getting what you want
because actually this wasn't as somebody
said this morning Frogmore Cottage just
a place where they lay their heads it
actually came with the umbrella of
security that you get as being possible
please
protection they're so obsessed about
privacy and security so they won't come
there anymore hang on you've got what
you want we respond to you these two
apparently are by your yardstick
obsessed with privacy and security right
they've just done a six-part Netflix
documentary into their private lives at
home one they don't care about privacy
they want to sell it secondly on
security Harry was unbelievably reckless
in the book to boast about his Taliban
kill numbers and to describe the Taliban
victims that he killed as chess pieces
he by doing that immeasurably worsened
the security for his family immeasurably
as any military expert will tell you so
don't let me hear them talk anymore
about privacy and safety when he has so
deliberately invaded his own privacy and
worsened theirs I'm nearly pointing out
that whether he's exacerbated his own
situation or not they are always very
concerned we saw them last summer they
hardly left from the cottage except
after all nor was there any security
incident around them they have highly
paid bodyguards but you know what pairs
you've got what you want and in the end
it's a nail in your own someone I want
and yes yes you've been you've been
shouting them down sorry no no
I think they are a malevolent Duo intent
on fleecing their Royal titles for
hundreds of millions of dollars and
causing Untold damage to their family
and the institution of the process I do
believe that but I haven't evicted them
from this home Harry's father as a
victim from the home Harry's brother
wanted them evicted from this home I'm
damn sure of it because they are sick
and tired of not just them being trashed
but their wives being attracted by these
two Kevin makes it this is you've got
your finger on the Tabloid pass this if
they don't come to the coronation
in terms of attention it this is a
depletion I'm sorry
nobody cares look there's grotesque
inequality out here in unfairness when
these houses are standing empty in a
country with a homelessness uh crisis
but if they're not there at the
coronation they won't be missed no in
truth the event will just it's the other
way around if they are there they become
a massive distraction and abundant way
if I were with William and Charles and
Kate and Camilla I wouldn't trust the
parents um as far as I could throw them
they could remember Harry went to Prince
Philip's funeral and he then went and
had a private conversation with Charles
and William immediately afterwards at
the scene of the funeral and then he put
all of that in his book this is a guy
who was ranted about the media about
tabloid editors like me for invading his
family's privacy and all this kind of
garbage and yet there he is invading his
family's privacy at the most
excruciatingly private time revealing
conversation Michael Andrew in a front
row at the coronation
you're presuming you're presuming we
want that uh exactly and
ask you why would you even want them
there why would you want to see a pair
that have trashed their family for years
why do you want monarchy bashes there
because actually that's cancel the hall
event that's an easy will let's scrap it
save the money and I know it's hard you
know the pain so you know what you know
what I think Harry is something of a
victim
and yes he's made mistakes I think
they've slightly lost you yeah who've
lost You've Lost Your Venom about this
you've lost your spark you've lost the
ability to rise up and defend them
because in your heart you know Tessa
Dunlop I've been writing about them the
whole time do you know what you do by
you I've just seen that by watching a
helium balloon when it sucks out you
know it's like there's a slow like but
actually You've Lost That Thing That
crackle yeah no where you felt genuinely
felt they were right no now you think
you know what they're just they've lost
me no what saddens me Pez is that and
I'm right no is that there you are
listening your lips thinking that you've
won some something but the bigger
picture is our monarchy by all of this
has been depleted and actually is a
monarchist site on Saturday no actually
what Charles has done in my view very
smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy and his reputation from these
two flamethrowers from these two
flamethrowers who keep wanting to trash
it and burn into the ground lovely to
see you test lovely to see you Esther
and Kevin I think you're all staying
actually I think we are all right well
in that case I'm gonna see you after the
break as well well next to that
extraordinary story convicted male
pedophile decides they're a woman we had
a similar story like this of course up
in Scotland with the rapist but the
prosecutor is suspended for refusing to
use the right pronouns and acknowledge
them as sheep security joins me live
next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel nope
what are you every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
about one two
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
thank you
prosecutor say Santa has been suspended
in Los Angeles for dead maiming and
misgendering a convicted trans child
molester warning that she is trying to
gain the system the case involves James
Tubbs now Hannah Tubbs who begin
identifying as a woman after her I'll be
calling her after his 2014 arrest the
sexually assaulting a child Thomas is
also accused of murder with a lead
prosecutor Shea Center because at times
maybe pretending to be a trans woman to
have an easier time in German of course
we've just had a very similar story up
in Scotland Santa joins me now thank you
very much indeed for joining me this is
such a it's made me speechless we've
just had a story in Scotland over here
in the UK of a a transgender rapist who
was a man when he committed these two
rapes pretending according to his
ex-wife to be a female so that he could
then be put into a women's prison which
is exactly what happened and then it was
such an outcry uh that he got was
returned to a Men's prison where he is
now and the and the head of the Scottish
Parliament the first uh the first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon had to resign
in disgrace over this whole Scandal this
reminds me of that
um how has this happened how could it be
that you are suspended for misgendering
a pedophile who's killed someone
I'm just as surprised as you are who
would have ever thought that a
prosecutor by bringing hard evidence to
their Administration so I took evidence
to the upper Administration telling them
that we have a child molester pretending
to be transgender
so they could orchestrate a fraud on the
system and put themselves into a
juvenile facility
so this was a 26 year old adult man
who was sentenced as a juvenile
and was placed into a juvenile facility
and then was pretending to be trans
so to be classified as a girl
essentially
and by bringing this to their attention
I was punished for not using the correct
pronoun
I mean it's absolutely even as you're
saying this I'm just shaking my head in
total disbelief that you get suspended
for pointing out what seems to me to be
an absolutely clear-cut case of somebody
deliberately gaming the system and
playing off what has become certainly in
California this incredibly woke
onslaught of gender activism that you
have essentially become a victim of this
correct so I work for a man named George
gascon and he cares more about virtue
signaling and his Progressive policy
than he does about protecting children
than he does about the victims in the
case so he wants to punish his
prosecutors for not using the correct
pronoun
instead of punishing you know the child
molesters
and the truth is you did use the correct
pronoun as far as I'm concerned I'm not
going to call this person she
in the same way I'm not going to call
this rapist up in Scotland she they're
not they're men they're men abusing the
system so they can be put into female
facilities so that they can potentially
prey on women again that's it seems to
me completely obvious that's what
they're doing and they get a softer time
of course in a women's prison if they
can be successful
exactly and uh when I say correct I mean
their preferred pronoun so because I
heard or may have heard of child
molesters feelings gascon wants to
punish me it's incredible we are even in
the world look it's incredible to me
we're even in the world
where a convicted killer robber
pedophile
has the brass neck to demand the use of
any preferred pronoun
and then a legal system led by a D.A in
LA county goes along with this nonsense
right it's crazy and the most ironic
part is is that the murder child
molester isn't the offended party here
it's the members of gascon's executive
team they were offended for this child
molester and they're the ones that filed
the complaint
and had me suspended
so I didn't even offend the child
molester I landed gas gone
all his feelings are hurt so these
things I call the man-to-man
honestly it is absolutely mind-boggling
what has happened to you what's the
latest are you going to get allowed back
or what's happening
it's a five-day suspension so I will
return at the end of my suspension but
there'll probably be another one waiting
for me this is just retaliation gas guns
under a crusade to uh punish and uh
terminate anybody who speaks out against
him well you know what I admire your
honesty and on my your guts because
James Tubbs is a man and he's not going
to be called she or they or them by me
ever uh thank you very much indeed uh I
appreciate you joining me
okay thank you for having me
I keep saying the world's gone mad this
is completely nuts yeah there's usually
a bit more to it though isn't there yeah
and I think there is in this case
another other accusations uh if it was
just as explained yes well I know it's
the Daily Mail the mail website referred
to Jim strawcana as she why well because
if that's how somebody wants to be
called that's it wait you put them in
where you put normal is it because it
when I when I've said I want to be
called hot hotter hottest the hottest
man in the world nobody goes along with
it that's my preferred bro now no one
agrees no no you're now you're being
ridiculous now you're being ridiculous
all right take a break come back and
talk about this and also about Jeremy
Clarkson who has now been Let Go by ITV
I know that feeling
um evolving a a a conflict with Meghan
Markle I know that feeling too so we'll
talk about that after the break
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no we're gonna use uh every
little helps for God's sake is nothing
original anymore it's finger licking
Goods I'm loving it look let's be honest
we don't have any fancy speech writers
here but we do and I promise you discuss
the issues that matter to you yes I'm
back talk TV not with Morgan just before
him Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me
just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
's reaction to those explosive lockdown
Revelations rocking Westminster plus
King Charles evix Harry and Megan from
their Windsor pad before offering to
Andrew and Ed Sheeran opens up about his
recent roller coaster ride revealing how
it affected his new album all of that
and more at nine o'clock
welcome back Esther testing table we're
visiting one of our regular pack members
Ava Santina she's actually at the
emerald Stadium tonight uh as an Everton
fan with her dad and just sent me this
message on WhatsApp for pour over having
a terrible night as my beloved Arsenal
Crush Everton to pieces I know enjoy
your evening over
um we left on a cliffhanger about Jeremy
Clarkson so apparently there's not dated
statement from ITV saying well we've
recorded the next series and as with all
series we'll make won't make any more
decisions until after that so they're
slightly hedging their bets they're not
actually saying Clarkson is canceled I
guess the question is should you be it's
so inflammatory that word canceled can I
just extract it from
you're literally looking at somebody who
has canceled do you know you're not
canceled because you're saying right
there no no somebody somebody Rupert
Murdoch who owns the talk TV and the
company actually came and gave me a job
he had a rebirth like the Phoenix sunset
thankfully he believes he believes in
free speech but the truth is I was
canceled from Good Morning Britain at a
time when it became the number one
morning show in the country and I was
canceled because I refused to believe
Meghan Markle now I'd have to be
canceled for believing it let's return
to the question of Jeremy Clarkson who I
think hasn't been canceled but I think
ITV they've certainly tried but they are
sensing the direction of travel he's
passed his prime
I think his farm things all over the
shop and on the farm subject he can go
and grow tomatoes but actually in terms
of hosting a mainstream if people are
watching him growing tomatoes what
happens
no well he should obviously they're
going to go on ratings but that there
were reports that there was very clear
that they didn't want to support what he
said about Megan even though he you know
released an apology so apparently
it was still an apology but this is the
thing there's always such a double
standard even though he's apologized
because it's who it's coming from they
get to to play this oh but it's not
enough should he prostrate himself on
the ground
before Christmas they said
my issue with the whole won't regain is
that even when you do issue a groveling
apology It's never enough yeah they
never accept it they throw it back in
your face this went much wider than your
little walk Brigade and that's why I
think ITV will plow them up and let them
spend more time on his farm shops
for a clumsy stupid bad joke which was
intended as a joke
[Music]
but should he actually lose his ITV it
was it was really vile and he stuck by
it for some time yes until he saw public
opinion was so wide against him even his
daughter came out and dreams
he was already knocked off our state
broadcaster for lamping someone so
offset he's behaved badly he said
honestly to be fair he lapped me a lot
earlier than that hey look I'm gonna
stop the campaign to get you job I can't
believe that I'm the one who's got the
scar on my head from his fist and I'm
the one defending him anyway I've just
seen a second coming for you there's a
gap on a big quiz show on ITV I know you
can actually now you're talking yeah
come back Who Wants To Be A Millionaire
yeah
yeah it's great
let's move on shall we because he was
there thanks back but that's it from me
whatever up to like Jeremy Clarkson Keep
It Uncensored good night
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]